the normative culture for a lot of  modern women is that they use the years  up to the age of 30 to pursue their  career heavily and then they get to 30  and they realize you know and it's a  real thing you know biological clock and  go oh well if I'm gonna have kids I kind  of need to start planning for it now  yeah and then what happens is they start  prioritizing having to find me and stuff  which is fair enough but then they start  asking for the different kind of man so  what they were asking for before was the  attractive guy that all the other girls  ones maybe the rappers whatever the hot  guy or this at all and then they get to  you know 30 they want early 30s or  whatever and they're like yo that guy  was fun but he wasn't gonna be  commitment